so in previous videos we talked about
the claim that if I have two random
variables x and y that are independent
then the variance of the sum of those
two random variables or the difference
of those two random variables is going
to be equal to the sum of the variances
so that if you have independent random
variables your variation is going to
increase when you take a sum or a
difference and we've built a little bit
of intuition there what I want to talk
about in this video it's really about
building even more intuition is get a
gut feeling for why this independence is
important for making this claim and to
get that intuition let's look at two
random variables that are definitely
random variables but that are definitely
not independent so let's say let's let X
is equal to the number of hours that the
next person you meet so I'll say random
person random person slept yesterday and
let's say that Y is equal to the number
of hours that same person person was
awake yesterday and appreciate why these
are not independent random variables one
of them is going to completely determine
the other if I slept eight hours
yesterday then I'm going then I would
have been awake for 16 hours if I slept
for 16 hours and I would have been awake
for eight hours we know that X plus y
even though they're random variables and
there could be variation in X and there
could be variation in Y but for any
given person remember these are still
based on that same person X plus y is
always going to be equal to 24 hours so
these are not independent not in the
pendant if you're given one of the
variables it would completely determine
what the other variable is the
probability of getting a certain value
for one variable is going to be very
different
given what value you got for the other
variable so they're not independent
all so in this situation if someone said
let's just say for the sake of argument
that the variance of X the variance of X
is equal to I don't know let's say it's
equal to 4 and the units for variance it
would be squared hours so 4 hours
squared we could say that the standard
deviation for X in this case would be 2
hours and let's say that the variance or
let's say the standard deviation of Y is
also equal to 2 hours and let's say that
the variance of Y variance of Y well it
would be the square of the standard
deviation so it would be 4 hours 4 hours
squared would be our units so if we just
tried to blindly say oh I'm just gonna
apply this this little expression this
claim we had without thinking about the
independence we would try to say well
then the variance of X plus y the
variance of X plus y must be equal to
the sum of their variances so it would
be 4 plus 4 so is it equal to 8 hours
squared well that doesn't make any sense
because we know that a random variable
that is equal to X plus y that this is
always going to be 24 hours in fact it's
not going to have any variation X plus y
is always going to be 24 hours so for
these two random variables because they
are so connected they are not depend
independent at all this is actually
going to be 0 there is zero variance
here
X plus y is always going to be 24 at
least on earth where we have 24-hour day
I guess if someone lived on another
planet or something that it could be
slightly different and we're assuming
that we have an exactly 24-hour day on
earth so this is to give you a gut sense
of why independence matters for making
this claim and if you have things that
are not independent it gives you a good
sense for why this claim doesn't hold up
as much